when a former president passes away it's
appropriate to celebrate his life his
achievements and to remind the public of
his record in his legacy sadly though
with the death of George HW Bush some of
the media and politicians from both
parties are abusing this moment to trash
instead the sitting president as the
Bush motorcade was making its way to the
Capitol for the last time MSNBC's Nicole
Wallace a former Bush aide herself could
not restrain herself I think what
everyone's getting at is that under
Donald Trump the office of the
presidency has been debased in a way
that is unimaginable for people who
served every past president I think
what's lost in this moment is our
reverence and our dependence and our and
the way we need and rely upon the
elegance and the traditions of the
presidency let's get this straight she's
talking about reverence and she's
trashing the current present president
as the motorcade is inching its way up
Capitol Hill and then there was this gem
from earlier in the day let's see what
happens at Wednesday's memorial service
my prediction is that Trump fakes more
respect for families whose unprecedented
history of public service has repeatedly
belittled then he goes back to making a
mockery of the very office George Bush
and this nation long revered well think
about it this way President Bush was a
man who loved his country loved his
family
his faith and his friends he was a war
hero and a dedicated public servant
throughout his most of his life so are
these folks really honoring that legacy
and his innate sense of decency and
kindness by slashing the man who entered
the White House 25 years after him look
even if you don't care for President
Trump even if you just hate President
Trump
try showing just a little bit of class
and decorum as Bush 41 would have the
hits on Trump subtle and
not subtle at all have been interwoven
throughout the commentary and the
coverage they both believe that the
presidency is bigger than themselves
which is not something that that this
president always adheres to what George
Herbert Walker Bush is being remembered
for this week is is in a tweet or isn't
a press release or nothing much more
than his fundamental character I do not
know how it's going to work when Donald
Trump is an ex-president and Spiti
erratically a member of this club I
really think it's gonna change because I
don't think these men who share
something in common really share that in
common with Donald Trump at some point
you don't even know what to say to these
people that was Ron Klain by the way
they lack all sense of decency they
reduce a presidential death to just a
political battering ram like any other
issue but what you hear if you listen
closely is the last gasp of an
embittered establishment now as we've
seen across Europe and across much of
the United States populism is swapping
the old guard whether it's on the right
or on the left so rather than direct
their anger at Trump the establishment
frankly in both parties should be
directing it at themselves for it is
their policies that the voters turned
against in 2016 things like open borders
China trade NAFTA high taxes endless
wars those were Trump policies those
were the policies of the establishment
and the establishment GOP errs
apparently think that the weight of what
went back the people that they lost to
Trump is to belittle the president
non-stop even during formal and informal
on-air eulogies and tributes at a time
like this when a father a grandfather a
great-grandfather and a former president
has died we should be bigger than the
petty politics of the moment I think we
should be capable of uniting as
Americans and celebrating the best of
George HW Bush without resorting to the
same old usual political snark and
calumny
and isn't that what President Bush would
have wanted and that's the angle